What do you think is the biggest challenge facing the field of interactive rendering at this point?
I think it's mobile graphics. Everything seems, everything is going in that
direction right now. Things are moving away from the desktop onto the pads and
the phones. And when you go from a standpoint of trying to get performance per
dollar or performance per, in the, in the film industry it's performance for
BTU of cooling capacity.
[LAUGH]
And now we're going into, performance per watt of power that you can have, on
your device. It, that's a really interesting challenge for how to get what you
want on your device for that little tiny bit of power.
&gt;&gt; Managing complexity. We have so much high definition data, like. Sometimes you
just want to render a house but the bolts in the house all contain a million
polygons. How do you turn that rich information into something that is just the
most important for rendering a pretty image? I think that's the big thing.
&gt;&gt; I think in my field, coming from that, that maker, everyone is a designer,
standpoint, is, is that, that play between 3D printing, and physical objects,
and rendering, and the, the hardship that is when I create something on the
screen, I can do it in whatever I want. When I create that reality, sometimes
the reality doesn't
[LAUGH]
match up with the rendering.